y realmente ahora hablar de economía
aquí en directo américa francés 24 esto
con daniela blandón dani bienvenida
vamos entonces a empezar hablando por
una de las noticias del día que después
vamos a ampliar con nuestro invitado la
reserva federal de eeuu subió su tasa de
interés o la radón muy buenos días y
bueno se lo pongo en palabras muy
sencillas los analistas lo dicen y lo
describen mejor como el fin del dinero
barato y es que una subida de tasas lo
que implica es que acceder a
financiación o al dinero será más caro
que antes en un movimiento que tuvo
pocos sorpresas para el mercado la
reserva federal aumentó su tasa de
intervención en un cuarto de punto
porcentual o sea 25 puntos básicos y
ahora se ubica en un rango de entre 0,25
y 0,50 por ciento hay que decir que es
la primera vez desde 2018 que la fed
eleva sus tipos de interés de hecho en
la pandemia la mayoría de bancos
centrales lo que hicieron o lo que hizo
fue reducir al máximo sus tasas de esa
manera a la gente le era más fácil
acceder al crédito y reactivar el
consumo en plena crisis pero raúl es un
trabajo efecto inflacionarios como ya lo
hemos visto la intención ahora es quitar
esos estímulos porque la inflación se
salió de control a febrero ya rondaba el
8% en eeuu una cifra que no veían hace
40 años la reserva federal también
redujo la proyección de crecimiento para
este año del 4 por ciento al 2,8
escuchemos
estamos viendo precios más altos del
petróleo de las materias primas y
creemos que eso influirá en el pib hasta
cierto punto esto es parte de lo que
movió esas evaluaciones a la baja pero
recuerden ese 28 por ciento es un fuerte
crecimiento económico
danny ayer también lo estábamos hablando
el fondo monetariointernacional respiro
porque rusia dijo haber honrado el pago
de sus obligaciones en dólares no claro
el miércoles ya había cumplido un plazo
que era clave ya lo habíamos dicho para
que rusia pagara ciento como 117 dos
millones de dólares de intereses de
bonos recibidos anteriormente analistas
y el mismo fondo internacional monetario
internacional como usted lo dice daban
casi por descontado que rusia no tendría
cómo acceder a sus reservas
internacionales para hacer este pago
pero el kremlin dijo que si lo hizo y no
especificó si en dólares o en rublos de
todas maneras en este último caso el
mercado financiero lo consideraría un
default hay que ver entonces si
realmente
esa transferencia pero le pregunto si
entonces rusia tiene más vencimientos
próximos de deudas claro que sí pues
rusia tiene 15 unos internacionales
vigentes un bono recordemos es un papel
que emiten los gobiernos centrales para
financiarse y pagan intereses al que los
compre se estima que el total de la
deuda es de 40 mil millones de dólares y
que alrededor de la mitad está en manos
de inversionistas internacionales estos
117 millones de dólares son apenas el
primer vencimiento desde que inició la
guerra en marzo vienen otros intereses
por 615 millones de dólares y también el
4 de abril debe hacer un pago de capital
por 2 mil millones de dólares y en
américa latina' daniela todos nos
queremos mucho y todos tratamos de
ayudarnos también mucho por eso netflix
busca estrategias para que sus usuarios
no le hagan trampa cómo es esto raúl
usted si sabía yo no lo sabía que una de
las cláusulas del servicio de streaming
de netflix es que yo otros también como
street line es que quienes compartan una
cuenta vivan en la misma casa eso es
difícil de comprobarlo por eso me
inquieta saber cómo lo haría pues en la
práctica esto no está ocurriendo lo digo
en mi caso en el socio en el mío también
me tiene mezclado de claro por eso el
gigante de streaming quiere poner en
cintura a esos usuarios como nosotros
que no cumplen la norma y anunció que
está probando funciones específica en
chile costa rica y perú para cobrarles
un valor adicional inicialmente
comenzaría permitiendo a los usuarios de
sus planes estándar y premium agregar
hasta dos personas por fuera del hogar y
así tiene éxito pues lo va a aplicar a
otros países y pues lo pagamos sin
ningún problema a knicks cuál es la
razón que da la empresa para justificar
estos ensayos pues mire dicen que cómo
están ahora las cosas no están
recibiendo los ingresos suficientes para
poder invertir en nuevos contenidos lo
que hicimos nosotros fue analizar las
cifras entonces de netflix mire cómo lo
vemos esta plataforma de streaming sigue
siendo la más grande del mundo por
número de suscriptores ya llegan a 222
millones los ingresos en 2021 fueron de
unos 30 mil millones de dólares es decir
19 por ciento más y las ganancias en
2021 de cinco mil millones de dólares
pues crecieron un 85 por ciento
al año anterior no es que estén tampoco
está mal ya no paga un montón yo tengo
como cinco pantallas por ahí por eso él
ayuda a mis papás con esos indicadores a
pues hubo un día mixto para las bolsas
del mundo iniciando con asia al alza a
hong kong acumula un explosivo repunte
de casi 17 por ciento en apenas dos días
después de que china prometiera apoyo
para las industrias y en europa si hay
descensos por cuenta de la decisión de
la fed por quien fue menos agresiva de
lo que estaba esperando el mercado y que
no tiene como cifra el día
375 mil euros esta es la multa máxima
que solicita un fiscal contra la
plataforma de reparto de comida de
liberum ante un tribunal en parís
después de acusarla de trabajo
encubierto es decir raúl alegan que esta
startup en su momento no les dio a los
repartidores el correspondiente estatus
de asalariados sino que los trataba como
autónomos daniela y que ese conmigo
porque vamos a hablar de economía con
este segundo invitado
[Música]